Italy which has recorded fewer than half
the number of infections as China has
now overtaken China's death toll 427
people died in Italy in the past 24
hours taking Italy's total to three
thousand four hundred and five 156
deaths more than China ba Spain's
numbers are rising rapidly to more than
a hundred dead in the past see why live
Ron's Health Minister said on average
one person there dies from the virus
every 10 minutes Michel Barnier the
European Union's chief brexit negotiator
assess the positive for covered 19 the
69 year old says he's doing well and is
following the necessary instructions and
on a positive note
China has recorded its first stay with
no person-to-person infections we begin
our coverage with this reports from Paul
Brennan the head of the World Health
Organization has called coronavirus the
enemy of humanity in this intensive care
unit in the Italian city of Bergamo it's
easy to see why this footage filmed by
the head doctor gives just a glimpse of
the life and death struggles taking
place across Italy and across the world
all 80 beds here are occupied it's a
crowd at frantic overwhelming place the
system is on the brink 100 percent
saturation normally out of these 80 beds
three or four recover and can live in a
particular day and normally we are then
forced to bring in three or four others
we have a very precarious and difficult
balance isolation is a cold hard
necessity family members cannot visit
here
they cannot comfort or support her with
19 brings a solitary death one of the
saddest things but we know that girion
epidemics the only way to save those who
are outside is to not allow contacts we
try where possible to let them talk on
their cell phones or video calls but
sometimes they die when they are still
intubated so the court could not happen
we know that isolation is a very
important sacrifice but it is needed so
that people outside will not guess
temporary field hospitals try to relieve
the pressure the epidemic is roaring
through the population here and the
doctors are struggling to keep up the
widespread shortage of medical supplies
is having fatal consequences for the
staff in Catania a doctor who is forced
to work without wearing gloves has now
died of the virus in Bergamo province
alone 110 of the 600 medical staff have
fallen ill we are in full emergency with
this coronavirus pani Mia our elf
personnel nurses and physicians are
working round the clock
countless hour to fight this incredible
situation we do not know how long this
Panda Mia will last and the current
measures Italy 60 million people are
only allowed to travel for work medical
reasons or emergencies most shops accept
groceries and pharmacies are supposed to
remain closed until March 25th you will
see very little people around
we are following on TV internet
situation but on the other way we try
also not to be overwhelmed by by
information this is a danger there
elsewhere though the restrictions have
not been so strictly observed and faced
with no visible slowdown in the pace of
infections a lockdown is set to be
tightened further and the deadline of it
extended this crisis has been compared
to a war and at the moment the virus is
winning all Brennan al-jazeera